- [Conan] Now I want
to apologize for this.
We've been very busy doing these shows.
I did not get to eat lunch today.
I didn't have a chance.
So can I just take a second, could someone
bring me out a sandwich, please?
I just want a, I would
love to eat, thank you.
And thank you for bringing them
through those space age doors, yeah.
Thank you.
- [Voiceover] There he is.
- [Conan] It's great.
You just applauded a sandwich.
(audience cheering)
That's how good the Comic-Con crowds are.
He asked for a sandwich and there it was!
Wait a minute, this sandwich is huge.
There's no way I can eat this whole thing.
I need to cut it in half.
Andy, do you have a knife?
- [Andy] They don't let me have knives.
- [Conan] Okay.
(audience laughing)
That's right, me neither.
I guess I'll just have
to throw it in the trash,
I mean, there's nothing else I can do.
- [Andy] No, just ask
Bruce to cut it for you.
- [Conan] You're right.
Hey, Bruce, can you please come out here?
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
(clapping)
(cheering)
- [Bruce] What's up, Ginger?
- [Conan] Well, I need
to cut this sandwich.
I was wondering if you
could maybe give me a hand.
- [Bruce] Sure.
How about that hand?
- [Conan] Yeah.
- [Bruce] Yeah, you better
step back little girl.
- [Conan] Okay.
(laughs)
- [Bruce] All right you
crusty son of a bitch.
(revving)
Come get some!
Oh yeah, oh yeah!
(Conan laughs)
(revving)
- [Conan] Wow, incredible.
(audience cheering)
Thank you, Bruce, that's,
that's fantastic, thank you.
- [Bruce] You're welcome, you're welcome.
If there's anything else you need,
I'll be in my dressing room,
just polishing the old blade
if you know what I mean.
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
Of course I mean masturbating.
- [Conan] Yes, I know.
(audience laughing)
Bruce Campbell everybody.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
The second season of Ash Versus Evil Dead
premiers on Stars this October.
A lot more show coming
up, we'll be right back.